we are more than halfway through the
school year and halfway through Clark
County's first full year of using a new
online resource yep
but has it been useful and effective for
students Brian will explains what paper
is and why you may want to encourage
your child to take advantage of it
Dr Lindeman ended up telling us that
there's this resource called paper tutor
and we ended up using it for our peer
reviews everything is on one platform
and the students can use that as much as
they need to hey I'm doing a project
on the rules of compass with the
implementation of paper here at CCSD
Schools students can get the help they
need anytime anywhere and on any device
I was surprised that this is a resource
available because I'm not able to stay
after school having that resource at
home at any time would be awesome paper
is for Clark County School District
students here at ATEC Philip Cutler the
CEO of paper was visiting and heard from
those who use the service frequently Dr
Victoria lindemann's class use it for
writing she's heard there's not enough
kids or staff using it so I think
teachers are reluctant to try yet one
more program however this program
is so unique in what it's doing because
it has that human element
while students type on the keyboard they
know a real person is on the other end
to help them with their writing math
problems science or history questions
you can also show teachers what it's
actually being used for we've found
really interesting here in Clark County
in Las Vegas is that we've seen over a
thousand students actually use our
College admissions essay review feature
so we've got a lot of students thinking
about what they're going to be doing
when they graduate the visit from Cutler
was one of the ways to help generate
more awareness of this free resource
reporting at Advanced Technologies
Academy Brian will 8 news now Clark
County School tells us their contract
with paper is year to year and there's
an item on the agenda to evaluate it in
the next year for the coming weeks